[Music]
before we start this video i just want
to briefly mention that only 20 of you
are subscribed so if you enjoy the
channel please consider subscribing to
support future content hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory today we're going to be
discussing a question i presume that all
of us wondered to ourselves as children
can a muggle become magical i mean what
young harry potter fan didn't secretly
hope that their letter was on its way
from hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry on their 11th and 12th or maybe
even 13th birthday of course i'm keenly
aware that invitation letters to
hogwarts are mailed out to children on
their 11th birthdays but would it be so
outside the realm of possibility that a
child or two had been overlooked on
their 11th birthday and had to be
contacted the next school year letters
also get lost in the mail all the time
you know i'd almost go so far as to bet
that each and every one of you watching
this video at one time or another
wondered whether or not you could become
a witch or wizard even without your
invitation to hogwarts am i right or am
i right i'm pretty certain that i'm
right in any case for a question that's
clearly been asked by so many children
and perhaps the occasional adult or two
the answer is dare i say a little
complex let's break it down shall we to
start let's spell out pun intended of
course what we're asking here
can someone born without magical powers
gain the ability to perform magic later
in life
if i had to give a one-word answer i
would probably simply say no
but i truly don't believe that that
covers it and also it's a terribly lame
and boring video that would be for you
all okay so anyway jk rowling has said
that nobody knows exactly where magic
comes from
but she's also shared that she views
magic much like any other talent popping
up in certain individuals often
inherited but not always
well that's that you may be thinking
either you're born with it or you're not
but can't certain talents be latent only
to be discovered and perfected later in
life for example someone with the gift
of musicality or athleticism may be
predisposed to be good at those things
but then only really shows how gifted
they are with a bit of practice
so wouldn't it be reasonable to assume
that someone who was unaware they had
any magical powers could discover them
later on and learn how to wield their
gift hmm but again i suppose that isn't
a muggle becoming magical simply a witch
or wizard coming late to the party if
you will which brings us round to the
topic of what makes a person magical to
begin with well we've already covered
that nobody truly knows where magic
comes from but if we go on the
assumption that the talent metaphor best
describes what it means to have magical
abilities where does one harbor those
powers since rowling has also mentioned
that the wizarding gene is a dominant
one it seems fair to assume that magic
is in fact present within the person's
biological makeup this would mean that
wizarding dna is fundamentally different
from muggle dna as it suggests that
magical people have certain special
genes that give them their abilities
which of course would mean that muggles
are lacking in those same genes this
could also explain why some witches and
wizards are more powerful and better at
magic than others
magic is in their genes to varying
degrees it would also explain why most
magical children are born to witches and
wizards rather than muggle parents that
is they inherit the magical genes as
rolling says it's a dominant gene so
this makes sense but just like the genes
that decide a person's hair color or
height can seemingly come out of nowhere
such as a red-headed child born to two
brunettes magic can resurface within a
child born to non-magical people
i say resurface since in this instance
it's more likely that a relative or two
way back when would have possessed magic
in their dna
these magical genes could have then been
wiped out by the birth of the squib a
non-magical child born to a witch and
wizard who then married a mughal only to
come back about a few generations later
on the topic of squibs their very
existence also puts a stop to the idea
that muggles could become magical
because let's face it if anyone with
magical abilities would want to gain the
ability to perform magic it would be a
squib without magical talents scribs
often live within the wizarding world as
a sort of outsider
knowing about and surrounded by magic
without the means to perform it
themselves
sounds pretty miserable to me
so if they could become magical wouldn't
they in any case if you believe that
magic comes from one's dna it's pretty
hard to argue that someone born without
the wizarding gene could later develop
it i think the only possibility here is
that a muggle-born witch or wizard who
possesses the gene doesn't realize that
they have magical powers until they're
informed of it
this is likely the scenario that many
muggleborn students experience after
they receive their letter from hogwarts
or any other wizarding school
however if you don't like the dna
explanation there is another fun fan
theory that i'm rather fond of that
magic comes from one's soul
in this theory the idea is that magic
and your ability to perform it is
directly linked to your soul
this could explain a couple of specific
instances in the wizarding world of
harry potter for one thing it would
account for the magical abilities that
harry possesses only as a result of
becoming one of voldemort's accidental
horcruxes
typically a horcrux is an object that's
been created by splitting wizard's soul
into pieces to achieve immortality
however in this particular case the
piece of voldemort's soul latched onto
the only other living thing it could
find harry after he attempted to murder
him as an infant
and so after taking up lodgings inside
of harry the horcrux which is literally
a piece of voldemort's soul
seemed to provide harry with magical
abilities that were also the dark lords
for example harry was able to speak
parcel tongue the rare language of
serpents that only a select few witches
and wizards innately understand he could
also perform legitimacy on voldemort
meaning he could enter the dark lord's
mind and sense what he was feeling
this was another magical gift that
voldemort also possessed in terms of
today's question however i don't think
it's really possible to alter one's soul
after birth you're likely born with one
soul that remains the same throughout
your life don't you think and so even if
magic is harbored in your soul i still
don't think a muggle can become magical
my guess unless they were inadvertently
made into a horcrux like harry was this
leaves it just one last thing to cover
the fact that in the trailer for the
upcoming fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore jacob kowalski the american
nomad is given a wand by albus
dumbledore of course there are several
plausible explanations for why
dumbledore may have given jacob a wand
which i've explored in great detail in
the harry potter theory video why does
jacob have a wand but there's also the
possibility that perhaps jacob has
become magical
isn't there
although rather more likely i think is
that if he possesses any magic at all
it's been there all along and he just
hasn't been aware of it perhaps he's
always had a tiny bit of magic just not
enough to be invited to a wizarding
school
this would align well with the idea that
every witch and wizard have varying
degrees of magical abilities
so it's possible to think that certain
people could possess an almost
undetectable amount of magic all in all
i think the answer to the question of
whether or not a muggle can become
magical is a pretty resounding no
regardless of if you believe that magic
comes from your genes or your soul i
think it's pretty unlikely that magic
can be an acquired skill
true young witches and wizards must
attend educational institutions to learn
a variety of magical abilities but one
thing remains clear you must have a
predisposition to magic in order to
perform it this is further proven by the
fact that muggles aren't able to wield
magical objects such as ones
for example james steward the no magic
co-founder of ilvermorny school of
witchcraft and wizardry had a one to
rebel in response to him casually waving
it in the air as invariably happens when
a nomadch waves a wand it rebelled
james was sent flying backwards across
the clearing hit a tree and was knocked
out cold and so sadly for all of our 11
year old selves i don't believe it's
possible for someone born without powers
to gain the ability to do magic later in
life whether through biology theology or
education
which brings us to the end of today's
video as always i'd love to know what
you think
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed the video don't forget to like
and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember
imperfect understanding is often more
dangerous than ignorance
[Music]
you